hey I'm bangbang and I'm a tattoo artist
in New York City today we're going to
look at some celebrity tattoos yeah
David Beckham's tattoos are really
iconic many people have duplicated it or
attempted to but I mean I can spot this
tattoo and not see anything else until
like this is David Beckham this tattoo
works because it complements shape it
almost feels like armor placed on his
back it's placed in an appropriate spot
it complements the body well so it's
it's a good one maybe something people
wouldn't notice that I see is the
reference used for the person is I think
it's someone jumping off a diving board
any time an artists used as a body very
often times unless they're an expert
illustrator we use a body reference so
this pose of them looking down jumping
up point toes pointed down arms straight
out I think it's a diver
I love the rocks tribal tattoo who's
wearing travel tattoos that are cooler
than that this guy's a hero I hope he
runs for president I kind of miss his
original tattoo he had a bull that was
really easily identifiable which is
something that I think makes successful
tattoos it was just iconic when these
tattoos are made they're made body
specific this was drawn on his body this
isn't something that was that comes off
of a picture on a wall and they stick it
on this is specifically made for his
anatomies I think it's pretty cool this
Polynesian tattoo was probably in the
realm of 10 to 15 hours depends on
really depends on the artist speed how
well the skin takes ink actually I'm
forgetting his arms probably massive
that's like tattooing someone's back so
it could take a little longer he's a big
boy
who wears tattoos better than Rihanna
first of all the Sanskrit on her hip
moves a little as her hip moves which
carries your eye into her next shape a
little more it almost forces you to see
more curved and then I think her gun
tattoo is is great cuz it's just iconic
Lee she's a badass [ __ ] like who else
should have a little gun tattoo it's
like Rihanna
that was a strange story it's like I had
tattooed her you know a couple years
prior to doing that gun tattoo and she
had a little gun necklace my name's bang
bang it's like of course I'm gonna try
to talk her into hey let's get a little
gun tattoo let's do it and so a couple
years later we did and it was almost on
her shoulders there was almost two of
them and one on each side just above for
armpit and when I put the stencils on
and I looked at her it was the only
thing I could see and that's not the
goal when you're tattooing especially
when you're tattooing someone iconic
you're tattooing a woman like you know
her face and her neck and her shoulders
and that is her image and so I I didn't
want to do something that dominated that
and so when you look at Rihanna's
tattoos they're oftentimes delicate and
even though when you stare at her she
has you know one on her collar and one
of her neck and another one on her
clavicle and she you see Rihanna
you don't see Rihanna's tattoo you know
it's not like some overwhelming tattoo
so we took them off the front of her and
put it on her ribs I liked it much
better
sometimes the frame makes the artwork so
this is the case here I take no credit I
made both of these tattoos but she makes
them look good yeah this is a American
traditional tattoo like you would see
made in the 20s and it's great it's
really well done this is done to pay
tribute to that time period and style of
tattooing so this isn't this isn't done
with the intent of trying to make this
girl look like a real mermaid or
anything other than trying to stay true
to the time period and the style that
this artwork was created in so it works
because it's true to what it trying to
be trying to be a traditional American
Americana tattoo when tattoos were
introduced in America in the 1920s in
New York on the Bowery this is what they
were making and they were tattooing with
no gloves on and you know their stencils
were really rudimentary and they made
flash designs people come in pick them
out and that's what you'd get kid and
these were sailor tattoos these two
these these were made for sailors in
town because they were the ones who are
getting
tattooed at the time so of course it's a
mermaid that makes a lot of sense
I love the statue I don't have any
traditional tattoos I don't make
traditional tattoos but I like when I
see them done well I like that she has a
theme you know make it red I love that
Kylie has a direction and she knows what
she wants
I like that her style is little red
tattoos I don't think I've ever met a
person that has a bunch of little red
tattoos so I like I like that it's
unique we use really small needles to
make these tattoos so when people think
of a needle they think of one needle and
that it's not actually like that with
tattooing it's several needles and
they're grouped together very much like
this and they come to a point in that
space in between each needle is what
leaves ink behind so if it's open it's
gonna leave more ink behind over a
bigger area and if it's quite tight like
the area that we damage your skin is is
much smaller but it is harder to make it
consistent so think if you're using a
pencil and you try to draw a straight
line you'll see a lot of inconsistencies
in that very thin straight line now if
you take a big sharpie and try to draw a
straight line it's gonna look much
smoother so the thicker and bigger the
line is it's it's almost safer when
we're tattooing because you can't see
any of that wiggle or any of our
imperfections so it's it's harder to
make smaller lines these take 30 seconds
easy money all of your nerves are in
your hands and your feet so you can feel
things so you can keep your balance so
yeah your pain receptors right there
that looks like it hurt I can relate I
like his barbed wire knuckles a lot and
I like the faces he's got like a photo
album on his knuckles it's kind of funny
well they work because he's post him
alone you know so if he wasn't posting
alone you know somebody walked in and I
saw these tattoos really we got some
work to do but I think oftentimes when
people have so many tattoos we fall in
love with them they become part of us so
the portraits are impressively healed
for how small they are you could tell
who everyone is which is all which is
awesome
immediately what catches my eyes the
bear is a really common
photograph of a really famous bear and
so it's a our job when we tattoo to try
to find something unique it's really
tough when I see it I see a really
common commonly used bear reference and
I'm curious that might actually be the
same one as on Justin Bieber's chest it
is right you'll be twinsies you don't
even know it I don't think post Malone
or Justin Beiber pissed that they have
the same bear tank girl like who is Tank
Girl more than Ruby Rose she's she's
kind of iconic her tattoos are really
cool it's it's rerender dart so it is
someone else's are rendered into skin
and sometimes that works and sometimes
it doesn't in this case for this design
style like it worked perfect for a
tattoo and it works perfect on her
specifically something you wouldn't
notice about this that's not fully
tattooed this is actually a mix of
pigment and skin so oftentimes when
tattoos are fully colored they're every
inch of them is solidly colored when I
made this it's kind of a different
technique tried to use a lot of her skin
and blend into it and so it's more skin
than you think this is cool this is a
super cool tattoo it's super unique this
tattoo makes me happy to look at I
imagine it does the same for her it's
not overwhelming for this like I just
love its uniqueness this is a this is a
brave tattoo to jump into because this
isn't something that's quote-unquote you
know traditionally done this pastel
palette of coloring and I like that it's
in a circle I'd be friends with scarlet
johansson if she didn't have this so as
far as first tattoos go this is a good
one like well done kid he has better
tattoos than his dad actually I think
the amount of skin leftover around it is
a good thing I don't always think
tattoos need to be dominating of a body
part I think I think they can you know
be just displayed on a body part so I
like that it's not overwhelming it's
tattooed well it's not a common tattoo
it's a difficult tattoo to make so it's
highly rendered and small I've met him
he's awesome humble kid who really
really loves tattoos and saves his money
so that he can get them I know how much
Brooklyn loves his tattoos and it's it's
it's great that he has good ones yeah I
would love to see these a little bit
bigger
they kind of like birthmarks from here I
think she got these in my store I think
john-boy did these I think I was there
when she got these for me
when tattoos aren't easily identifiable
if I have to take a moment even a moment
to figure out what it is and my brain
doesn't automatically do it for me I
tend to redesign most people that view
your tattoos are not viewing them as
closely as you are actually people
perceive you a bit further away I like I
like the shape on the spa so I like that
it's a little circle in that spot I
almost feel like maybe it should be a
little circle or a dot it's like kind of
cool it doesn't require an enormous
skill to do these tattoos it does
require skill to do them perfectly
traditionally the this tattoo is a
little too tight for us to say it will
age really well those gaps in between
those letters those skin spaces close
over time they won't say seek forever
they're all done well and I'm sure they
all mean a lot but I wish Steph Curry
would get some tattoos there maybe like
form to his body he's got an incredible
physique and these little tiny little
model tats I would love to get a big
tattoo on Steph Curry call me